what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
january 2nd a beautiful [__] day to
be alive
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
cbd lion listen when it comes to cbd
there's nobody better than cbd line how
do i know
do you see any black tape on there no
because i'm all out of it i used it all
i've eaten three quarters of the gummies
i gave the joint to my neighbor he loved
it i believe the cbd lion
more than most people believe in
themselves you understand me why because
they're the best go to cbdline.com right
now and read the third party lab results
and you tell me
read go learn about cbd
cbn cby the advantages and how cbd can
help you
go to cbdline.com right now and press in
joey or church and get 20 off
delivered right to your house uncle
joey's joint is also brought to you by
another one of my personal favorites on
it
on it is the [__] best when it comes
to supplement alpha brain shroom tech
shroom tech immune shroom tech sport the
the snacks i mean the protein bars nine
grams of protein if you don't like pills
they have powder now they have
powder for the shroom tech for the alpha
brain i mean on it never stops i can't
help you with the club bats and the
kettlebells
but i can help you with the supplements
go to honor.com right now and take a
look
at the great selection of supplements
that they got every month
i get the same melatonin alpha brain
the protein bar
shroom text immune shroom tech sport
new mood these are all things i use i
switch them around you know like i'll
always take the magnesium but new mood
helps you rest also forget all that do
me a favor go to honor.com right now
take a look at what they got
read up on the mct oil they have so many
things that you want to get just pick
one a month and give it a try but it all
starts with you by going to honor.com
right now
and pressing in church or joey and get
10 off
delivered right to your [__]
house that's how we do it let's get this
[__] party started
on a monday morning
oh
yeah and that's a wednesday morning what
the [__] am i saying
on a wednesday morning
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday june the [__] second a
new month
a new set of rules and a new set of
priorities i want to talk to you about
something today now that this we're
winding down and everything is [__]
opening up there's another problem
looming a lot of people
a lot of people know about it a lot of
people don't know a lot about a lot of
people going through it
during the [__] pandemic you know we
got shut in and uh
if you used to drink at five 5 30 after
work
i'm sure that your drinking schedule
shifted a little bit
you know you were home nobody was there
to watch you
you could do a shot at one which is very
innocent i'm not judging anybody you
know
uh that was also the same came true with
people who do
illicit drugs you know whether it's
snorting coke or smoking reefer you know
then had nowhere to go things got a
little early and then what did they do
they started giving you extra money
during the pandemic so now you had this
extra [__] money
and now i'm hearing across the country
that rehabs are [__] packed like
people are [__] going to rehabs left
and [__] right because they lost
control
over the pandemic now let's be as honest
as we can here and frank as we can
if anybody lost control over the
pandemic in the beginning it was me i
[__] lost my mind i mean it's just
between the fear i had never experienced
this before
and you're sitting there watching tv and
they're showing you freezers
full of people dying and you don't know
what the [__] going on so you know
some people got affected by it some
people didn't for me
i turned to what i knew best was
marijuana and edibles and i started
taking my anxiety medication and you
know
i
knew because i was doing all these
things like let me at least not drink
i mean during the pandemic uh while i
was in l.a i probably had one shot at
rogan's
before we left the the last podcast i
did with him
that i think spotify did put up and did
keep who gives the [__] if they didn't
and then uh
i also once i got here
i drank a white claw jimmy's one sunday
and realized [__] vodka kills me
and then one night i went out and
whenever i go out with my wife and
mercy another family i always to just be
normal because everybody's got a
cocktail or a beer
i try to get a sangria one five ounce
sangria six weight watching points
nobody gets their [__] feelings hurt
you know so
but one night i drank an old-fashioned
after it and that put me over the top
and i realized that whiskey is no longer
can no longer be in joey diaz's uh life
whiskey and joey diaz i mean hard liquor
and joey diaz
just don't agree no more so
i went uh
you know i didn't have a drinking
problem but i knew that
when i [__] got here my smoking when
i first landed and was staying in
somerset
my smoking i was putting down it had to
be 10 joints a [__] day
and i don't know how many milligrams of
vegetables a day you know and i had to
take a long
hard look at myself and i did what i had
to do and here we are
but sobriety is something that
it's [__] hard man
it's really [__] hard
and i got introduced to sobriety the
first time in 85 i got introduced to aaa
you know i don't know if there was an n
a back then
don't quote me or whatever i don't know
i went to a a a teacher of mine mr
terranova who first helped me out
when i was homeless you know
he didn't force me but he kind of did he
said these meetings would be good for
you
and i and i'll tell you i went to a
couple meetings and
they are eye awakening
you know these are like hardcore
new jersey a.a meetings
people insulting people
people telling people shut the [__] up
you're not a real alky i'm a real alky
when i drink i don't even use ice cubes
you know [__] like that like it was
[__] like i would go
and then i would tell him bring me
because
i need to see more of this [__] you know
and i would go there and i never shared
i never told anything i never raised my
hand i didn't really
um
you know i just watched you know and
then
time moved on and i forgot all about aaa
and
you know i got myself arrested and all
this [__] and then i moved to colorado
and you know
the drugs were free there and i kept
going at it and then i got locked up
and when i got locked up
they had a.a meetings in the prison if
you
have ever been in prison
uh you will do every anything like
bible study if you're a greek orthodox
your show even though you're not greek
or anything to get you out of that
[__] cell you know what i'm saying
so i would go to any religious meetings
i would go to any
group therapy meetings and i would also
go to aaa and i wouldn't share i would
just sit there
listen to the stories blah blah blah
blah blah once i got out when you get
into a halfway house
part of the [__] treatment is to go
to aaa meetings
and i [__] hate it i'm not gonna lie
to nobody i'm not putting anybody down
here i'm just letting you know how i
felt when i was 25 years old they would
force me to go to them and i would sit
there and go what the [__]
this was boulder colorado where
everybody was like well
you know i went off the rails on wine
coolers shut the [__] up i'm over here
doing an ounce of blow and eating pills
and drinking [__] fat tie
and you're over here because you drink
wine coolers it was just i always felt
like
weird and then i ended up getting into
more trouble and they threw me into a
[__]
outpatient rehab which i felt at the
time was a complete waste
i didn't like the the methods of therapy
it was like they were picking a scab
to upset you and i didn't like that
either you know
but
the
when you're in that halfway house you
have to be [__] sober and towards the
end
you know i tried to do it as legit as i
could you know i wasn't snorting coke
yes i was smoking pot just rolling up a
thin joint
and i would just take like
two hits off it and turn it off and it
wouldn't go over the thc level of my
body when i would piss
so that's what i did and that's how i
maintained until i got out of the
program and you know listen when i was
doing all that [__]
the only person i was hurting was myself
because i wasn't doing the program right
you know
and
you know the cocaine flowed i got into
comedy and
that's what this is all about you know
once you get into [__] comedy there's
nobody watching you
you know when you do one nighters they
just feed you the [__] drinks
what do you think they sell at a bar
coloring books
drugs coke pills reefer you know
whatever the [__] gasoline powder i
don't [__] know
but there's nothing good at a bar after
10 o'clock at night you know if you
notice a lot of comics are in recovery a
lot of comics or somewhere in their
career
they know they can't get ahead unless
they quit doing what they're doing i.e
ron white just recently got sober you
know i know bill bird doesn't drink i
know
dean doesn't drink i know a lot of guys
who started out in the business and but
one day
you're like i got to make a choice
between
my career
or alcohol because or drugs if i keep
going in this direction it's going to
ruin my [__] career and that's what
happens to most people
in the last
six months without mentioning names
on my patreon i have sent
three people to aaa if they want to
write something on patreon or go to
twitter and write something that i sent
them you know they were like i'm lost i
don't know what to do
and i got it from rich voss because i
hang out with rich and i talk to rich
and i know that deep into the pandemic
rich i would meet him for lunch
and he would tell me that he would do
zoom meetings for aaa
so i told all these people anybody who
contacted me over the pandemic whether
on patreon or facebook or twitter on
instagram i told them all the same thing
i go you gotta hit a meeting
and people were like why a meeting why
not rehab
you know man
again this is one man's opinion who has
been
a [__] criminal and a [__] drug
addict all his [__] life
i think rehab sometimes it's a force
it what i mean it's a force it's a force
that's making you go in there
i think that 80 of people that go to
rehab don't want to really get clean
they just go to rehab because they have
to because of a dui or
something happened or whatever
20 of those people are people that woke
up one morning and said [__] i can't
suck 12 dicks anymore i need to go to a
[__] rehab
you know i can't put myself in this
position and they go in there
and they give it a new york [__] try
but you know you know what the
statistics are not [__] bueno not
[__] bueno you know
over the years when i got out of prison
i accepted that i was gonna keep doing
cocaine i got sick and tired of quitting
you know you just get sick and tired i'm
gonna confuse the last time i'm snorting
coke i'll never do this again i'm gonna
be a better man and two days later
you're back in the bag i mean it's a
broken [__] record
and i raised my hand i was the king of
it so i i just said this is not gonna
work
you know i'll just try to do everything
in moderation and then
when it comes to cocaine there's no
moderation because you don't stop until
you're [__] broke you know
so for a guy like me i know
all about getting clean
what you're feeling what you're not
feeling
and i knew one thing for me
i knew that
november 8 2007
when i stopped doing cocaine
the first thing that happens when you
get sober is you think about
and you look at yourself and you judge
yourself and you say to yourself
there's no way
i could do a day
without cocaine there's no way
i'm gonna make it through that wedding
without a drink there's no way i can
make it through a day of work
without smoking pot when you think about
getting sober
there's no way you see it happening in
your mind and that's where you lose
that's where you lose when you don't see
it happening is where you lose how do i
know you're looking at it i tried to
quit 80 000 [__] times
but you don't really want to you don't
really want to you
you're just lying to yourself
you're just yesing yourself to death and
i'm the king of doing that i can yes
myself to death for [__] years and
that's why i did blow for 27 [__]
years
and the last seven
trust me every time i did a line
it was hard
the last seven years from 2000 to 2007
i was just snorting out of snorting i
didn't want to snort but i had no other
i had no other options it was
i can't describe to you what a dark
place i went into in 2006
and 2007. i went into the darkest place
i've ever been in my life and then i
added heroin to the [__] mix and that
summer of 2007 i don't even [__]
remember that summer
i don't even [__] remember it you
know
but when i
decided not to snort coke
i took
unconsciously
and consciously i'm not gonna
i took
what i had learned over the years from
aa and n a
and applied it to me in my journaling
did i go to a few meetings i'm not gonna
lie to you i went to a few meetings in
california i went to a few meetings in
the house i think i went to like maybe
one meeting in hollywood and maybe two
in the valley
and
i didn't think that they would help me i
didn't think that they would have
the impact on me
of me journaling listen guys let's face
it you have to think about who you are
i'm a stand-up comic
that means i have the balls to go up in
front of a brick wall with a microphone
by myself
in front of strangers i was an only
child
i love to snort cook by myself i love to
smoke pop by myself i'm the type of guy
i like to eat by myself i like to do
[__] by myself i enjoy myself you know
what i'm saying
so the whole group thing
i think that's why it didn't work out
for me
it wasn't because you know
i didn't want to be a friend of john's
or whatever no that's not the fact i
didn't think
the group thing would work for me but
i think it works for 70 to 80 percent of
people
when you really think about it and apply
the steps
i have
probably in my life right now
i got to tell you i have 10 people who
are lifelong
n a or a a people
you know and i don't mean to put rich
foster's uh
life on
you know but i talked to him a lot and i
see
his passion for it
you know i have another dear friend that
i was i know since the sixth grade we
just spoke last week i checked in with
him because i knew he had to go to rehab
in january you know he relapsed after
you know this pandemic was rough on
people he was home all alone he's got no
wife no [__] kid you know he's my age
uh his job made him [__] sit at the
house and do the work
so he eventually relapsed he caught
himself
he put himself in a voluntary detox
he went to a rehab for two weeks
and he signed himself out and got into
the program and he's doing great he said
something to me last week that was
[__] interesting he said that
god is a gentleman
that if you invite god into your life
he'll come in but he's a gentleman he'll
never [__] mingle
unless you invite him at first i wanted
to hang up on him i thought he was crazy
but then listen i'm the type of guy that
i don't care what you need to do
to get there
i don't care what you need to do if you
need to drink 22 [__] alpha brains
a day when i got off cocaine
alpha brain really helped me i went on
alpha brain i remember telling rogan one
night
the alpha brain is really helping me now
i'm not on cocaine he looked at me like
are you [__] crazy it's the truth it
really helped me when i first got off
cocaine my mind was missing something
something was not right with my mind it
wasn't firing
and that's how i got introduced to alpha
brain through marcus and the whole thing
and that's how i fell in love with it
and that's why i don't tell this to a
lot of people is the first time i've
disclosed this
but when i quit when i quit cocaine my
brain was [__] shot
and one day we were on the road and
rogan had a couple [__] shroom techs
uh alpha brains and i took a couple
alpha brains and i went home and i'm
like this makes me feel a lot better
since i got off the coke and i went on
an alpha brain for like six [__]
months until
i felt [__] normal again i mean this
is what you need to do i don't care what
you do
to get there now for me
my whole thing listen
i watch my godfather smoke for years
when i was a little [__] kid from the
age of four to [__] seven
i saw my godfather roll smoke a joint go
to a movie we go get a slice of pizza
he'd giggle i did this with him
us in this room
it's a harmless [__] vice
marijuana is a harmless [__] vice
you've never seen nobody tell you that
they kill they people when they were
smoking weed or whatever i get it so
when i quit cocaine
i considered myself sober
because i wasn't on the drug
see
weed didn't make me go kidnap ken bella
drinking alcohol didn't make me kidnap
ken bella
i kidnapped ken bella because i wanted
to
but i was also not under the influence
of cocaine i was under
the hammer of cocaine i wasn't i at the
time of the kidnapping i'd love to tell
you i was high and that's why i took the
machine gun out and that's what made me
kidnap no it didn't
no i'd love to tell you that i'd love to
you know sell you that story but
i kidnapped him because i was under the
hammer of cocaine not under the
influence
two different [__] things
so i learned a very important lesson so
to me getting sober meant getting off
the drug
that put me behind bars once i beat that
i thought i had it beat and i was doing
well with it
you know again do i think the i think
the edibles are harmless [__] vice
until they start affecting your life
what do i mean by that
if you don't go to work anything that
[__] makes you [__] up
then it's not a harmless vice anymore
but you popping an edible 11 o'clock at
night to watch a movie with your
girlfriend i can't get mad at you i you
know
i don't care if you have a glass of wine
i don't really give a [__]
but you're still not [__] sober you
know
and something about that always bothered
me
it really did it really [__] did and
then things started happening
that made me get more and more upset
with it
a couple years ago i watched the 30 for
30 with chris herron
he's a basketball player he played for
the celtics local boy out of boston you
know somewhere out of there i don't want
to you know like when i told bill burr
you're out of boston he's like nah i'm
30 miles north okay anyway
i don't want to piss nobody off he
played for the celtics so he's from the
boston area i watched this 30 for 30.
i watched him tell a story about having
a basketball uniform on
warming up with the celtics
and not having any vicodins or a pill a
certain pill don't percocet viking don't
quote me on this but he said that
he went outside on the street to the
corner
with his celtic uniform on
to meet the dude outside to give him the
pills
because he couldn't play without the
that is the most addicting
story i've ever heard in my life
and it's the most addicting story
because i lived through those stories
i went through those stories i got a
thousand of them i don't remember them
right now
but i did
stupid things like that that you wake up
the next day and go
i'll never tell nobody that story but i
did that for blow like i
you know i got on my hands and knees and
looked around the toilet bowl because i
thought there was a little rock on the
floor
i mean this is the [__] that you look at
years later and go
i don't even want that in my mind
anymore the things i did i remember
flushing an ounce of coke
because i kept seeing cars stop by my
window i was on the third floor of a
hotel and i was looking out the window
and the cars would stop so i went and
dumped an ounce of coke and when i went
downstairs i realized it was an atm
machine people kept pulling up to take
cash out and i dumped an ounce of
[__] coke out you know i got a
thousand of these embarrassing stories
you ever say something
and you [__] think about it 10 years
later and go i can't believe i said that
in that room
well i got about a thousand of those
[__] stories when i was on cocaine
you know
you know ruined
holidays ruined people's nights
you know
i still remember
being in like clark tennessee or
something one of those west virginia
towns
and driving an hour following a guy with
another comic that was innocent like guy
like mike or lee that don't know
anything about anything they just want
to be comedians and i'm making them dry
i didn't make them drive me at gunpoint
i asked them for a ride and i paid them
for gas to follow some [__] redneck
to a trailer for me to get [__] crank
to get high i got a thousand of these
[__] stories so i knew exactly what
chris herron was talking about
when he said that that gave me but but
for me i was a basketball player
you know i quit basketball after i was a
freshman because i
my feelings got hurt and i didn't want
to do it anymore but i know what it is
to i wanted to be a professional
basketball player when he said that i'm
like so here i am in the boston garden
the [__] the f this is like you know
where basketball was invented with red
all back
i'm on the [__] reds i'm on the
boston celtic team i'm [__] starting
but before my [__] game i can't play
because i don't have a viking or a
percocet or quaaluded me
so i'm gonna go out into the street with
my [__] uniform on and meet a dealer
that that was just
too much for me to comprehend so i
reached out to him i donated to his
[__] charity which i do ever since
then he came on the podcast
while i'm [__] talk this is a piece
of [__] that i am okay this is when i
started getting mad
he's on the podcast dropping knowledge
about sobriety we had to call in he's
dropping knowledge about sobriety and
what he was feeling and the second
chance his wife gave him and all this
[__]
and i'm loving all this stuff because
this is the stuff i [__] live for
and within that i'll never forget that's
you know and i'm embarrassed about this
somewhere in that night when i was
listening with the headphones on i still
remember
taking a hit off the joint and putting
the joint down and going what did i just
do
this guy is telling me a story about
redemption and all this [__] drug use
and that's [__] horrible he's trying
to help people he he has a rehab and his
whole family is involved in this and
here i am on the other end of the phone
smoking a [__] joint
what type of [__]
that was one episode that i regretted of
all time on the church that should have
been a drug free episode and we should
have done like 10 free drug free
episodes out of respect for [__]
chris but i didn't
i didn't even realize what i had done to
like a week later i'm like i can't
believe i was smoking pot
while i was talking on the phone to
chris herron a guy who's saving [__]
people on a daily basis
but me the dumb [__] pothead i am i
can't realize
that it just wasn't even [__] right
you don't know how bad i felt about that
podcast i should have taken it down but
i left it up
and i'm still embarrassed about it
but it was things like that that led us
to what we're going to talk about today
you know
that was one story that i was very
ashamed of that and it was like couple
days later i'm like i'm on the phone
with chris herron
and i'm smoking [__] dope what the
[__] is wrong with me
what the [__] kind of person you know
when i got off that [__] plane when i
moved here
i'll never forget going on youtube one
day to listen to music one night or
something
and i saw like an old church and i'm
like who is that guy
who is that
fat dude with a [__] t-shirt on
with bags under his eyes and his eyes
are [__] closed
he's a grown [__] 50 year old man
acting like a [__] two-year-old
i was ashamed i'm ashamed at times i'm
not going to [__] lie to you but it's
who the [__] i am i'm a [__] pothead
what do you want from me it's who the
[__] i am
so yeah
part of me was mad at what i had done
and this podcast that i was promoting
but part of me was like that's who the
[__] i am
i shouldn't be ashamed of who the [__] i
am
but then i got an email a couple months
later
and they were
not ridiculing me but
they were kind of checking me they were
checking me in and uh
he didn't check me in a gentlemanly way
but he checked me and he said that
you know i was glamorizing weed
that a lot of people might be taking
this wrong kids might be taking this
wrong
and i don't know if i told the [__] off
or whatever comment i made
you know
i just said yeah yeah yeah and then i
thought about it
i thought about it i thought about it
and i was like this guy's right
you know and i'm not trying to glamorize
it
i'm just showing you the weed that we
were getting in california at the time
that's it i was just helping some
friends of mine that have great weed
and i want you to get the great same
great wheat to it wasn't like i was
glamorizing it or whatever
we were too stupid we were caught up and
we were just getting high
and it [__] happens you know
but then we moved back here and i
started looking at my life
and i started seeing
you know we always think we're doing the
right thing until we take a close look
you gotta take a close look and i've
been told i've been mentioning this the
last four or five podcasts
and you have to check yourself from time
to time i took a close look
and i realized there was a lot of
[__] holes in my game a lot of holes
more than usual
more than what i [__] thought i
didn't think i was perfect but i didn't
think i was that bad of shape either
and i started cleaning up my game little
by little just little things there were
things i did that i didn't even know i
was doing
like the coffee thing i didn't even know
i was doing it my body didn't need it
anymore so i didn't know i was doing it
and then i just started little by little
you know i don't feel like smoking at
eight in the morning
i'll smoke after breakfast you know well
i don't want to go to the gym smelling
like weed those people are in potheads
at the gym
i smoke after the gym then i got to the
point where i would run in and go right
to the pipe and hit it and then just run
my whole day
off smoking [__] reefer and another
joint
and let's be honest with you
i was getting high
the first time if that
if that
look at the amount of edibles i had to
eat to get high on that show
if lee ate you know three things i
really ate six plus whatever i ate all
[__] day
you know whatever i was eating all day
you have no idea who i was bumping into
what weed store i was going to who i was
going to see to do a podcast
they had a bag of mushrooms they had
this they had that i was surrounded by
it still no excuse no excuse i was
taking those mushrooms i was eating them
i was giving them away to my friends you
know i was like a [__] drug peddler
myself i was giving [__] away people
would give me [__] that i couldn't use
and i was giving them away [__] i
would go to shows people would give me
pills pills that i wouldn't take i would
give those away it was a [__]
constant whatever and i'm like what the
[__] is all this
so whatever a month ago
you know i i just saw that
my weed intake was getting lower and
lower
and lower even i had the surgery i'm in
the house and i'm bored to death
but with all the pain pills and the
other medication i'm like i don't wanna
[__] smoke cause i'm feeling like
[__] enough with these [__] oxycotins
make you feel bad enough and the weed
wasn't doing anything to me so i'm like
you know what
i'm destroying my lungs
i'm smoking 15 [__] times a day after
a while i put away the [__] i went
and bought a pipe
my agent sent me a pipe so i had two
pipes i was [__] smoking you know i
was smoking that pipe 20 times a [__]
day nothing was happening
so i said you know what let's see let's
just work this backwards so i started
taking times when i would smoke i have a
thing you have to smoke by two o'clock
to go [__] your mother for the last 33
days i've been [__] my mother because
i haven't been smoking
so
you know i smoke i would smoke at one
and then i'd smoke at four but then you
know then i would smoke like a seven but
i would smoke downstairs it's winter
time sometimes i would go in the back
sometimes i'd come down
she's not stupid my little daughter when
she comes downstairs and she smells it
she won't say nothing
but she smells it
so all those little [__] things i
know a lot of people like joey she's
gonna find out about it anyway yeah but
now when she's eight
she doesn't deserve to find out about it
when she's eight a little down the line
when she's 12 she can handle that [__]
you know nobody can handle listen
i hate to say this to you but i've
always repeated this this is one of my
favorite lines of all time i saw my hero
getting high what are my chances of
getting high
my hero was my mother
my other hero my dad died from drugs so
when your heroes get high
what are your chances of getting [__]
high
yeah so i don't want her to smell that
yet
not yet not right now she's too innocent
she's too young and she's too you know
i don't want her how to think that her
dad well this is my medicine what are
you [__] talking about medicine
i don't i can't know so i'd rather not
so what happened over the last couple
[__] weeks was that
i just saw myself
not smoking not smoking and the other
thing was to covet i was scared to smoke
because i thought it would go into my
[__] lungs and every time i'd smoked
my lungs would burn so i'm like [__] i'm
getting cold i wasn't getting cold but i
never got cold but i got the [__]
vaccine i was fine but all those things
and i don't i just
don't think my body needed anymore so i
quit smoking 30 days ago all right no
big deal not quit
because i wanted to don't quote me on
that i just
wanted to give it a breather
all right so
it went on with that i gave it a little
breather the first week went by
i didn't [__] i didn't yell i didn't
scream
there was no real ability i didn't lose
sleep
the second week perfect better than the
first week
didn't lose sleep
didn't curse didn't get no real ability
the third week i can't lie to you one
night i went off last week the week
before
i went off on my wife upstairs i didn't
go off i just mentioned a couple things
to her
but i was in front of mercy and mercy
got upset and i go you know what
this is probably me tripping from the
reef let me go downstairs and get my
head together my wife came down a little
while later i apologized and she goes i
don't think it was the reefer she goes i
think you were just having a bad day
because i told like i'm sorry if i went
off before i think it was the reef i
already i immediately went to the reef
she was like no because i've seen how
you've been reacting the last couple of
weeks you've been fine
it's not the reef or what else is going
on with you and i go yeah i got this
other thing and she goes that's what
ballin you take care of it that was it
so
i haven't been irritable about it it's
not that i had a call like
you know and i do believe in the sponsor
i
let me tell you something when i
got into aaa
in
when i got out
i had a chick sponsor first she was a
[__]
she really was she was too dippy for me
but then i got another sponsor i got a
guy
and he was very very good
i forget what his name was i stayed
clean with him for about six months i
mean
clean
he had a good system you know
call me every day he wanted you to call
him every day call me every day at 10
let me know how you're feeling
let me know if you think you want to use
today i mean he was a very good sponsor
if you get high he didn't [__] like
one time i relapsed on reefer he didn't
beat me up he took me out to lunch and
he told me it was going to be a struggle
and to keep going to meetings and keep
working the fourth step and you know the
steps hey are great you know the first
step is give your life to somebody else
listen i did it with comedy i do it with
everything you can't control everything
you have to put your life into somebody
else's hands and that's where faith
comes in
if you're looking to get clean you got
to have a little bit of [__] faith
listen pick a god i don't give a [__] to
god what what you're thinking if you
don't believe in god just say there's a
higher power out there i i don't give a
[__] if you don't like god if you don't
want to hang out with buddha if you're
not a buddhist if you're not it doesn't
matter to me it's giving your life
to put in somebody else's hands that's
the beginning of it the fourth step is
taking a moral inventory which i do
every day when i journal
that's what i've been doing for the last
29 [__] years has taken a moral
inventory pretty much in a way
it's just done on a daily basis
a moral inventory of what the [__] is
going on with me i do it every day
sometimes i do in the morning
lately i've been doing it at night and
i'm getting more from it because i'm
reflecting on my day and what i learned
that day
so all these things help
towards your sobriety
but something else happened on the way
to the dance
for two weeks
for three weeks i sat here every day
and i was telling people i'm clean
i'm clean i haven't taken an anxiety
pill since i took the guitar lesson from
rudy sargent that day it was too [__]
intense it was too intense for me
and
you know i'm not smoking so i'm clean
but then i was like wait a second
i'm taking that [__] p at night
that's what i kept saying and i'm
putting those [__] edibles in there
too
and i said all right let me do this
let me do this
let me not put the edibles in the tea
and just drink the tea
so i did that for a week
i would just take the tea with the
magnesium
a couple cbds with [__] melatonin in
it
he slept good still out like a [__]
baby
out like a baby
but guess what something was eating away
at me
there was still two milligrams
of thc
in the tea
and five milligrams of cbd
now to some people you're like joey
that's nothing
but to me it was something
so saturday night i said [__] it
i'm not drinking
the tea anymore
i'm gonna give the tea a break i needed
to give it a break anyway because my
body was getting too used to it
you what i usually do is just not drink
it what i started doing now
was drink uh celestial seasonings makes
a great they make great [__] teas
if you need to wake up and you don't
like coffee drink lemon zinger that'll
put you in a different [__] world
i've been on the lemon zinger
since
1985.
i've been on lemon zinger if you go
upstairs to my tea there's two boxes
upstairs lemon zinger i love lemon
zinger it's been like a month since i
last drank one but once a month
i'll do a [__] lemon zinger and the
other one i like is that sleepy time tea
let me tell you something you put two of
those things
two bags and a cup of [__] coffee
rock-a-bye baby on the treetop when the
wind blows the cradle will rock whatever
the [__] the lyrics are i don't know i
haven't sang rock on my baby
in a long [__] time
but uh yeah so i've been taking sleepy
time
to magnesium tablets
i turned the tv off at 11
i practiced the guitar
once i feel a little [__] tired from
the magnesium
i go upstairs
and that's it so it's been three [__]
days
so guess what [__]
i am completely sober now
for three days
don't get carried away
it's wednesday i'm gonna drink my tea
tonight that's it i just wanna
i just wanna let you [__] know
that joey diaz could look you
[__] in the eye
and tell you
that i was sober for 72 hours go [__]
yourselves all he is i did it i [__]
did it because i tell you what i was
also i used to train with a girl in
boulder and she was
a big time a.a type of chick i'm talking
about
like if she had pain she would take
something completely different if she
had a cold
she wouldn't take a lot of the stuff
most people would take because they had
i mean she was that anal
it had little things of opiates or
whatever she was [__] insane about it
and i looked at it i i thought about her
beautiful girl beauty looked like mariah
carey stunk terribly though she was a
natural chick didn't shave her armpits
didn't want aluminum under her pits and
[__] she stunk terribly but she was a
dear friend of mine gorgeous but she was
such an aana chick
that there wasn't much she was allowed
to do like if she went for she had a
toothache she would have to take
something completely different she
couldn't take aspirins or pain pills
when she went to the dentist she wasn't
allowed to get put out her fear of
[__]
relapse was so [__] strong that i
mean i respected her for it and now i'm
looking at it but again
i don't ever want to be that sober like
i don't i don't
i don't ever want to be that sober i i
want to be able to do what the [__] i
want to do and i want you
to be able to do what the [__] you want
to do what does that mean
if you go to a bar one night and there's
a girl there and you have a cocktail and
the girl says do you want a line of coke
and if you want to do a line of coke you
could do it and drive home or take an
uber home and the next day you wake up
and go to work and then you don't do
coke for eight months you know that's
your life i'm not here to tell you
what's fun that's what i you know for me
listen i was the type of guy that i
wouldn't go out of the house if i didn't
have cocaine
that's what ruined me forever
that ruined my life forever
you know i was the type of guy that i
wouldn't go to a movie unless i could
smoke a joint
i'm not going to go to a movie unless i
can smoke a joke i can't watch that
movie unless you smoke a joint i was
always one of those [__] when i tell
you that i could not go out
and have a drink unless i had a pocket
of coke in me
unless i had 50 worth of cocaine in my
pocket
there was no way you were getting me out
to a bar to have a drink it was a waste
of [__] time what are you wasting my
time for i'm gonna go talk to people
with no coke
i mean that's why it took me so long to
quit coke because i thought that my
social
i wouldn't be even
the toughest thing was i thought i
wouldn't be funny anymore that was
really killing me what does [__]
cocaine have to do and then when i would
realize that when i would i would do
coke
the night before and i would get on
stage i would do horribly
because my heart and my soul weren't
connected to the [__] material so
you're always scared of what's gonna
happen if i stop doing this which i
remember when i went off the anxiety
pills i just went online
you know when duff mckagan told me he
goes i had a little problem i went on
tour one year because duff is spotless
clean
and he said he went on tour one year i
think with velvet revolver and he was
having some problems sleeping and he
started eating the footballs like i did
and he goes you just can't quit because
you'll have a stroke you gotta taper off
them so i went online i learned how to
taper off them and now they're done as
needed and let me tell you something if
i feel anxiety attack coming now
i'll breed that [__] out
everything i do has been to help me with
my anxiety attacks the walking the no
coffee the [__]
sleeping right i mean everything i mean
the coffee the [__] edibles in the
daytime my anxiety has dropped by 90
[__] percent i think i still have 10
percent anxiety to me like the end i was
going to a restaurant with a buddy of
mine
my neighbor frank called me because you
want to go get a pot roast sandwich
absolutely
and as i was going to meet him i had a
little bit of anxiety
i came up and i told my wife i go why do
i have anxiety i'm going to get a
sandwich
with my dear friend across the street
and his son and she goes i don't know
i go i know and the anxiety went away
and that was it
usually i would run downstairs and take
a [__] pill of football and then get
in the car no i'm not doing that no more
i'm learning how to cope with all this
stuff
listen i want a smoke pot
you have no idea how badly i've wanted
to smoke pot the last two days
in my world 30 days is enough
that's enough of a [__] sentence okay
i'm up to 33 [__] days right now i
have not smoked pot but i will tell you
something
i don't think i'm ready i don't think my
tolerance has gone down i don't think so
because two weeks ago three weeks ago
you guys saw what i was putting in those
[__] tees
yeah you're not ready yet trust me
trust me so i think i'm gonna give it to
the mid mid month
i'll roll the joint i'll make a video
i'll smoke it we'll all look at each
other we'll see how we're doing and then
we'll reevaluate how does that seem
we'll just smoke we'll look you you tell
me if my eyes are red enough if my eyes
get red enough and i get goofy and i
start drooling well
joe diaz in outer space then we'll
[__] continue to [__] smoke but if
not
we'll just do that and what i think i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna roll the joint
take a hit off it and when i say
whatever we'll turn that into an nfp
for [__] june that's what we'll do
it's that [__] easy i tell you
[__] i'm an idea man didn't i
tell you that [__] snuckers but i cannot
believe
till this day that i have been sober
for 72 [__] hours
no drugs only thing i've been taking is
my blood pressure medication
baby aspirin my nose steroid
listerine
my nose cleaner
for the snots you don't want no snots
getting up there i'm not allowed to use
afrin or afrix whatever the [__] [__]
is ever since i had the nose surgery
so i am [__] sober for the last 72
hours no thc
no cbd i put some ice on my knee i don't
know if that counts to being [__]
sober
that's it that's it so
i don't know if you guys have ever been
proud of me i hope you're proud of me
for being sober for 72 [__] hours and
being clean off smoking reefer
for 33 days trust me this is not going
to continue
i am not letting my [__] animal
savages down i'm just taking a little
breather so everything sounds a little
better the guitar
tv
my life the soundtrack of my life
everything will work a lot better so i'm
not quitting i'm not proud of this
i am proud about the sober i could at
least
say that i was sober for 72 hours
in the middle of all this [__] thing
with all this [__] going on but no
nothing's going on
we're about to open up [__] things so
it's great i was going to have a guest
today
but it's the first podcast of the month
and i said [__] it i'd rather come on
here with you
i wanted to talk to you guys about
sobriety because i know a lot of you
guys either know somebody
or having a problem with somebody that's
having a pro you're not having a problem
with somebody
but you know somebody who's kind of
slipping listen
nobody could afford a [__] rehab
right now
this is very easy go to a few meetings
just go to three meetings do me the
favor three meetings
they might work for you they might not
work for you if they don't work for you
that's fine
then we'll find an alternate
[__] solution
the notebook is always great
that fourth step you know i don't know
where to buy an aaa book or where to buy
an n a book i think you could find them
on amazon
or something but the fourth step
which is taking a moral inventory of
your life i mean
that shit's strong and that shit's
powerful and that shit's [__] real
maybe you just want to take a breather
like i did maybe
there's a party a lot you know i don't
know a lot about other pills you know
what to do with oxycontin i know that
you know oxycodone's the [__] or cotton
the [__] 40
and after a while you can't pay 40
dollars and after a while
you just dip down the heroin or whatever
the [__] that is for seven dollar bags i
don't know but listen man it all starts
with a [__] meeting
everybody there is very nice
nobody's gonna [__] judge you and so
what if they did
we put ourselves in this position by
being [__] junkies now we got to get
ourselves out of that position and
become functioning members of [__]
society that's what this is all about
do i want to be a functioning member of
society just saying that makes me sound
like a half a [__]
but it's it's it's at the end of the day
we have to do it
we'll do it for our friends for our
families for our kids for the people
around us you know i never in my life
thought that i would get off cocaine i
could guys i could look he's all in the
eye and tell you when i do a show i
never saw it coming i never saw it
coming
never did i imagine that i could ever
live a life
without clawing and stealing and
thinking about it you know
a wise man once told me in one of those
group therapy homes
you know when i was locked up in one of
those group therapy sessions this guy
was an older
if i was 25 he was maybe
my age now i was an older
african-american guy and he said
something that always stuck with me
and i hope this helps you as much as it
helped me
he goes think about all the energy and
effort
you put into getting that bag of weed
or that six-pack of alcohol or that bag
of coke you know for me
you got to go to the bank take the 40
out you have 58 the bank you don't have
60. so you got to take 40 out because
you got to leave 18 in there if not they
close your account now you got to find
somebody to borrow 20 dollars from you
everybody knows you're a [__] junkie
and nobody's going to lend you 20
unless you like stab yourself or flatten
your own tire or do something stupid you
know then you got to [__] get that
now after you borrow the 20
now you got to call the [__] coke
dealer and now the coke dealer tells you
he took his girlfriend out for their
anniversary because it was their
four-year anniversary you're a [__]
coke dealer you mutt you're not supposed
to have anniversaries you're supposed to
be sitting at home waiting for me to
[__] call you with my addicted
[__] personality and then he tells
you he can't be there till 10 so now
you're waiting and you're like [__] him
i'm gonna call somebody else so you
start making other calls and you call a
friend of yours and after it's all said
and done
you just wasted four hours of [__]
time
trying to get that bag of [__] dope
and now you're killing another eight
hours of your [__] mind
once you get the [__] powder so for a
guy like me i was averaging at least i
was throwing away nine hours of [__]
day
on cocaine between thinking about it and
all this [__] let me ask you guys a
question
when did you [__] hear about me
2010 2011 2012 2013 yes
it was five years after i quit cocaine
is that a coincidence or what the [__]
do you think that is you think i just
showed up on the [__] weeds of like
jesus
no
i had been at it for [__] years but
it took me quitting cocaine to put a
hundred percent effort into what i
really [__] loved which was doing
[__] comedy and making you guys laugh
and that's why i ended up a [__]
savage of a comic it was the comedy
storm it was my daughter my wife's love
and it was everything but the bottom
line was i freed up my mind
to do what i really wanted to do
which was do comedy
be a good husband be a good person and
be a good friend so if you can learn
anything from today's [__]
podcast
is to just do this step by step i'm not
expecting you
nothing happens overnight and anybody
that tells you is a [__] [__]
artist i'm telling you
just start taking the steps to clean
your life up you're gonna feel a lot
better and the success that you want is
right in front of your [__] hands
everything i wanted i got after i got
off the [__] cocaine that was the
damage drug
you know i'm not staying off the pot i'm
telling you right now i'm smoking pot
tonight i'm drinking that tea i will
post a picture of it tonight just to
prove it to you i'm only doing this
sober [__] for 72 hours don't expect me
to do this sober [__]
for [__] ever i want to be a misfit i
don't want to be completely sober when
it's time for me to complete be sober
i'll be [__] sober when i'm an angel
up in heaven with little [__] wings
flapping behind me i look like one of
those [__]
chubby little [__] whatever the
[__] the cupid's whatever the [__]
you call it
anyway i'm happy uh you watched today
i hope you learned something and i'm
happy that uh i stayed sober for 72
[__] hours completely sober
i feel great look at my eyeballs they
look great the veins are disappearing i
noticed that i did a quaalude one night
i busted like a vein up here i gots my
eyes got so red that the veins
just popped vessels up here and i could
tell i was looking at my eyes the other
day in the mirror i'm like hey
some of those [__] vessels
disappeared since i stopped smoking
reefer
so this is agree with me
if you're mad at me because i quit what
can i tell you i'm quitting for my
health you know i was watching
an ethan soupley video the other day you
know and the same thing was with me
listen
hollywood loves fat people
not for a leading role you're not gonna
[__]
you know
[__] lead a movie if you're 500
pounds
but they love fat people
i can tell you three [__] people who
booked like hell when they were fat
[__]
me eric i forget his last name if you
ever watch the movie blade
the fat guy he goes to visit the guy
that's like a blob in the bed
blade goes to talk to him eric williams
or something he was a comic from the
comedy store you got to see him now he
looks like a [__] skeleton he's like
a brown belt in jiu jitsu he lost all
the weight and ethan soupley and myself
i kept booking when i was 500 pounds
418. i booked whatever i wanted because
you're the fat guy
and you could fall into that watch that
movie uh
the original football nights what the
[__] is that called that movie they did
yeah
there's a fat kid in that movie the
original uh
texas knights uh
football nights or whatever they made
this movie about 20 years ago with the
kid from
whatever creek was in it the main guys
do from sons of anarchy yeah
the the fat kid in that movie
he was on fire he did the first taco
bell commercial with me with the dog
he did that movie friday night lights
that's what it's called friday night
lights
the fact in that movie
had surgery done
to do the the doctor told him he was
getting too fat
and he had the lap replacement and he
lost 200 pounds and guess what
he never booked another role again
i don't know if he committed suicide or
he recently died or something that's
what happens when you lose that weight
because hollywood likes you
a certain way if you're fat they want
you to always be the fat guy that's it
you're the fat guy and you'll work
forever but ethan souple even said he
goes i gave up hollywood roles
for my health
for me i gave up
you know everything for my [__]
health so
i gave up everything to be a better
comic i gave up you know a ton of [__]
to be where i am today nothing is just
going to be given to you and i
understand
drugs are great i'm not going to argue
with you i i [__] love doing them you
know me i'm not going to sit here and
tell you i love doing a hit of acid or
whatever but
if you want to grow you got to get off
and uh i think that this pandemic
[__] a lot of people up enough as it
is and if you're one of those people
listen
just put your life in god's hands
hit a meeting
journal
and find what works for you
i don't care that listen
people well if you don't do it this way
you're not gonna get clean listen i
stayed clean from cocaine
for 13 close to 14 years this november
i didn't do anything special i just
wrote in that journal and i looked at my
wife every day and i said i don't want
her to find me on the floor dead
pick something pick a reason
go for it and get your life together i
love you guys with all my [__] heart
thank you for watching today wednesday
june 2nd
i'll see you [__] monday
morning tip top [__] magoo
i will not be sober on monday i promise
you that i don't know if i'll be high on
uh smoking
but i will be high on uh
on the t for the night before
i love you [__] have a great day
stay black
we'll see you on monday morning
all right i want to thank you
[__] today for watching the
podcast
and talking about sobriety i love
talking about sobriety i can't believe
i've done this for 72 hours
but it'll be over quick don't worry
about none don't clap don't worry about
nothing i just want to thank the
sponsors this week
our sponsors are today
june 2nd wednesday the sponsors are cbd
lion listen
when it comes to cbd lion
when it comes to cbd i'm a cbd lion type
of guy
why because they've been there for me
with me for years
i didn't know how good the product
definitely was until i had surgery last
january that's when this product
really showed me what the [__] it was
between the bath ball
the cream the roll-on the tape if you
can see i have no tape left that's
because i used it all on my knee
and it worked
cbd line is a great company
what you need to do is go to cbd line
and read
read the third party lab results read
everything there is to know about cbd
and you will be [__] happy when the
product comes in the mail right now go
to cbdlion.com
read up on it i don't care if you want
to do the smoke the bath ball the
gummies the roll-on the tape i mean
they're all great
anything you get from cbd line is 100
percent
[__] solid and they're my people and
i love them to death so go to
cbdline.com right now
read look purchase if there's something
you want pressing code joey
church
joint
and get 20 off delivered right to your
[__] house you're gonna love cbd line
this is not some [__]
guy in a liquor store
or some guy in a gas station selling you
cbd lion
this is a real [__] company who puts
love
into everything they do
i trust cbd lion and so will you the
joint is also brought to you by onyx
listen to me i've been working with them
for 10 [__] years 11 years
tremendous on it you understand me and
i've been using that product even longer
than that i believe in alpha brain and
if you listen to this podcast i told you
why i believe in shroom tech i love the
protein bar i love the melatonin spray
you spray it right under your tongue you
sleep like a [__] baby that makes you
sober too the melatonin there's no drugs
in there either do me a favor go to
honor.com right now
take a look at their website take a look
at the supplements they have start with
alpha brain if you don't like alpha
brain if you're not thinking clear
within 30 days
call on it let them know you don't even
have to return the pills they'll return
the money you could keep the [__]
bills that's how good honor is that's
why i believe in alpha brain that's why
i believe in this company so do me a
favor go to honor.com right now take a
look at what they got
pressing code church or joey and get 10
percent off delivered right to your
[__] house and trust me once you try
the alpha brain you won't go back i want
to thank honett i want to thank cbd lion
i want to thank zip recruiter i want to
thank blue chu but most importantly i
want to thank you [__] for
listening supporting and always having
my back on the patreon side we got nfps
coming
mid month so if you're still into those
get on patreon and see if you get
yourself one
but beside that have a great weekend
i love you [__] and stay black
we'll be back monday morning ready to
rock your [__] world
i got a little [__] magic candle here
i love you [__] stay black have a
great weekend
so
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
you